en el espacio liminal entre los sueños y la realidad,
entre raza y género,
pobreza y abundancia,
ciencia y sociedad.
Soy a la vez negra y mujer.
Como el nacimiento de las estrellas del firmamento,
esta combinación robusta de conocimiento da un ejemplo brillante
de la fusión explosiva de identidades.
También soy astrofísica.
Estudio los blazares, agujeros negros hiperactivos, supermasivos,
que se sitúan en el centro de galaxias masivas
y disparan chorros en las cercanías de esos agujeros negros
a velocidades cercanas a las de la luz
en un proceso que aún tratamos de comprender cabalmente.
Soñé con ser astrofísica
desde los 12 años.
No tenía idea de que en ese momento,
según el archivo del Dr. Jamie Alexander de mujeres afro de EE.UU. en la física,
solo 18 mujeres negras en EE.UU. habían conseguido un doctorado.
en disciplinas relacionadas con física,
y que la primera mujer negra en graduarse con un doctorado en astronomía
lo hizo solo un año antes de mi nacimiento.
A lo largo del camino
encontré lo mejor y lo peor de la vida en la intersección:
la tremenda oportunidad de la autodefinición,
la colisión de expectativa y experiencia,
la euforia de los avances victoriosos
y, a veces,
el dolor explosivo de la regeneración.
Empecé mi experiencia universitaria cuando mi familia se había desmoronado.
Nuestra situación financiera se deshizo
ni bien mi padre dejó nuestras vidas.
Esta madre abandonada, mi hermana y yo,
dejamos la comodidad relativa de una vida de clase media
para adentrarnos en la lucha constante por llegar a fin de mes.
Fui una de casi un 60 % de mujeres negras
que enfrentan la limitación financiera en sus objetivos educativos.
Afortunadamente, la Universidad Estatal de Norfolk me dio financiación completa
y pude hacer mi licenciatura en física.
Tras graduarme, y a pesar de saber que quería doctorarme en astrofísica,
caí en las grietas.
Pero un cartel salvó mi sueño,
y algunas personas y programas increíbles.
La Sociedad Estadounidense de Física tenía este cartel hermoso
que animaba a los estudiantes negros a ser físicos.
Me sorprendió porque destacaba una niña negra,
quizá de unos 12 años,
que miraba con atención unas ecuaciones de física.
Recuerdo haber devuelto
la mirada a la pequeña niña
que primero se animó a soñar este sueño.
De inmediato escribí a la Sociedad
y solicité una copia del cartel,
que aún hoy cuelga en mi oficina.
Les describí en mi correo mi trayectoria educativa,
y mi deseo de embarcarme nuevamente en la búsqueda de la tesis doctoral.
Me dirigieron al Programa Puente de la Universidad Fisk-Vanderbilt,
una intersección de grados de maestría y doctorado
en dos instituciones.
Tras dos años fuera de la escuela, me aceptaron en el programa,
y me encontré nuevamente en camino al doctorado.
Tras conseguir mi maestría en física,
fui a Yale a terminar el doctorado.
Tras ocupar físicamente el espacio que en última instancia daría paso
a mis aspiraciones de la infancia,
anticipé un suave camino al doctorado.
(Risas)
Se hizo evidente de inmediato
que no todo el mundo estaba encantado de tener ese grado de liminalidad
en su espacio.
Muchos compañeros me condenaron al ostracismo,
y uno de ellos se atrevió a invitarme a "hacer lo que vine a hacer"
mientras empujaba los platos sucios frente de mí para que los limpiara.
Me gustaría decir que fue un hecho aislado,
pero para muchas mujeres negras
en ciencia, tecnología, ingeniería, matemática o ciencias básicas,
esto es algo que han soportado durante mucho tiempo.
El 100 % de las 60 mujeres negras
entrevistadas en un reciente estudio de Joan C. Williams en UC Hastings
informó enfrentar sesgo de género racial,
como ser confundidas con el personal de limpieza.
Esta confusión de identidad no fue informada
por ninguna mujer blanca entrevistada en ese estudio,
que comprendía 557 mujeres en total.
Si bien no hay nada inherentemente malo en una posición de limpieza,
y de hecho mis antepasados pudieron ir a la universidad
gracias a que sus padres tenían estos trabajos,
fue un intento claro por ponerme en mi lugar.
Aparte del indudable e intenso dolor de ese encuentro,
el verdadero problema es que mi apariencia
no debe indicar nada sobre mi capacidad.
No obstante, más allá de eso, pone de relieve
que las mujeres negras de ciencias duras no tienen las mismas dificultades
que tienen las mujeres en general o las personas negras.
Por eso hoy quiero destacar a las mujeres negras de las ciencias duras,
que inexorablemente, y sin complejos,
viven esa inseparable suma de identidades.
Las ciencias duras son en sí un término liminal,
y su verdadera riqueza no se puede apreciar
sin tener en cuenta el espacio liminal que existe entre las disciplinas.
La ciencia, la búsqueda de entender el mundo físico
por medio de la química, la física, la biología,
no puede lograrse en ausencia de las matemáticas.
La ingeniería requiere la aplicación de ciencias básicas y matemáticas
a la experiencia vivida.
La tecnología tiene una fuerte base de matemática,
ingeniería y ciencia.
La propia matemática juega el papel crítico de la piedra de Rosetta,
en la codificación y decodificación de los principios físicos del mundo.
Las ciencias duras están incompletas sin cada pieza individual.
Esto por no hablar de lo que se enriquecen
las ciencias duras al combinarse con otras disciplinas.
Esta charla tiene un doble objetivo:
Primero, decirles a las niñas negras, latinas, indígenas, aborígenes,
o cualquier otra mujer o niña
que descansen en la bendita intersección
de raza y género,
que pueden ser lo que quieran ser.
Espero en lo personal que sean astrofísicas,
pero más allá de eso, que sean lo que quieran ser.
No piensen ni por un minuto
que por ser quienes son
no pueden ser quienes imaginaron ser.
Aférrense a esos sueños
y dejen que los lleven a un mundo que ni siquiera imaginan.
Segundo, entre los asuntos más urgentes de nuestro tiempo,
la mayoría ahora encuentra su intersección con las ciencias duras.
Como sociedad global hemos resuelto
la mayoría de los temas simples de nuestro tiempo.
Los temas restantes requieren una investigación profunda
del espacio liminal entre disciplinas
para crear las soluciones multifacéticas del mañana.
Quién mejor para resolver estos problemas liminales
que quienes han enfrentado toda la vida desde las intersecciones.
Nosotros, como líderes de opinión que tomamos decisiones,
debemos dar los primeros pasos más allá de la diversidad
al territorio más rico y más robusto
de la plena inclusión y la igualdad de oportunidades.
Uno de mis ejemplos favoritos de excelencia liminal
viene de la difunta Dra. Claudia Alexander,
una mujer negra física del plasma,
que falleció el pasado julio tras luchar durante 10 años contra el cáncer de mama.
Encabezó por parte de la NASA el proyecto
de la misión Rosetta,
que se hizo famoso este año por el aterrizaje de un vehículo en un cometa,
y por la misión Galileo a Júpiter de USD 1500 millones,
dos victorias científicos de alto nivel
para la NASA, EE. UU. y el mundo.
La Dra. Alexander lo dijo así:
"Estoy acostumbrada a caminar entre dos culturas.
Para mí, es uno de los propósitos de mi vida
llevarnos de estados de ignorancia a estados de comprensión
mediante la exploración audaz que puede hacerse todos los días".
Esto muestra exactamente el poder de una persona liminal.
Ella tenía la capacidad técnica para dirigir
una de las misiones espaciales más ambiciosas de nuestro tiempo,
y entendía perfectamente su lugar
de ser exactamente quien era en el lugar que estaba.
Jessica Matthews, inventora de la línea SOCCKET de productos deportivos,
como balones de fútbol, que generan energías renovables durante el juego,
lo dijo así:
"Gran parte de la invención no consiste solo en crear cosas,
sino en entender a las personas
y a los sistemas que constituyen este mundo".
Cuento esta historia
y la historia de la Dra. Alexander y la de Jessica Matthews
porque, en esencia, son historias liminales,
historias de vidas vividas en el nexo de la raza, el género y la innovación.
A pesar de cuestiones implícitas y explícitas
de mi derecho de estar en un espacio de élite,
me enorgullece decirles que cuando me gradué,
fui la primera mujer negra en doctorarme en astrofísica
en los 312 años de historia de Yale hasta ese entonces.
(Aplausos)
Integro un grupo pequeño pero creciente de mujeres negras en ciencias duras
destinado a aportar nuevas perspectivas y dar a luz nuevas ideas
sobre los problemas más acuciantes de nuestro tiempo:
cosas como las desigualdades educativas,
la brutalidad policial, el VIH/SIDA, el cambio climático, la edición genética,
la inteligencia artificial y la exploración de Marte.
Esto es no decir nada de las cosas que ni siquiera hemos pensado todavía.
Las mujeres negras en ciencias duras ocupan uno de los temas más duros,
de los temas sociotecnológicos más apasionantes de nuestro tiempo.
Por lo tanto, estamos en una posición única
para contribuir y conducir estas conversaciones
para que incluyan una variedad más amplia de experiencia vivida.
Este punto de vista se puede ampliar a muchas personas liminales
cuyas experiencias, positivas y negativas,
enriquezcan las conversaciones de manera que sobrepasen
incluso los mejores grupos homogéneos.
Esto no es un pedido que nace de un deseo de encajar.
Es un recordatorio de que no podemos lograr los mejores resultados posibles
para toda la humanidad
precisamente sin esta colaboración,
esta conjunción de lo liminal,
lo vivido y experimentado en forma diferente,
con impactos dispares.
En pocas palabras, no podemos ser la expresión más excelsa
de nuestro genio colectivo
sin incluir a toda la humanidad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)